[Musique]
les vedettes débarque enfin à la mostra
de venise et malgré la pandémie à
l'arrière-plan le festival veut en
mettre plein la vue avec entre autres la
première mondiale du film d'une de denis
villeneuve ça signifie une victoire
c'est une victoire sur le fait que en
fait le film va apparaître
les projecteurs ont été braqués sur le
réalisateur pedro almodovar et son film
m'adresse pas râler la mettant en
vedette l'actrice penelope cruz lors de
la journée d'ouverture
[Musique]
demain on pourra voir le pouvoir du
chien réalisé par jane campion et
coproduit qu'on est québécois roger
frappier
dans la catégorie hors compétition le
film de denis villeneuve sera présenté
en grande première mondiale vendredi ce
sera la troisième fois que le
réalisateur québécois sera la mostra un
festival qui lui a porté chance en 2011
pour son film incendies puis en 2005
pour son film drive au feu rouge et
était extrêmement bien écrit et qui sait
parfaitement dans le calendrier
un autre québécois le réalisateur éric
gravel installé à paris depuis 20 ans
présentera son long métrage vendredi
de voir qu'un grand festival un intérêt
pour son fils basse et c'est
effectivement un rêve qui se réalise en
tout cas c'est une magnifique façon de
présenter son film la 78e édition de la
mostra sera un grand cru à la grande
surprise des organisateurs du festival
la surprise la plus intéressant le plus
grand c'était la qualité des films
jamais été aussi aussi à un personnage
j'ai eu l'impression que tout le monde
voulait recommencer sortir de chez eux
voyager montrer les filles au delà de la
fête le festival a lieu sous haute
surveillance sanitaire l'accès au tapis
rouge est limitée par camara aux
conférences de presse et certains
invités doivent subir un test de
dépistage tous les jours nous on serait
testée à tous les jours je sais je
déteste est positive ce matin je
pourrais pas être ici avec vous moi
depuis le début de la pandémie mes
pensées vont aux gens qui travaillent
dans les des gens là du front qui qui
font en sorte que notre société plus
fonctionner qui reçoivent tous ces gens
que c'est plus simple que je pense qu'à
ma première de france à la côte
sincèrement en attendant un retour à la
normale l'industrie cinématographique
s'affiche comme elle peut et elle
anticipe des jours meilleurs ici le wifi
depuis mai radio-canada venise